terr in Bangkok Thailand we've already
had one group it was amazing my name is
spam do it but the legend mark man how
you doing bro I'm doing well I mean men
like you said group a was insane so much
variety and it came down to the wire to
find out who of course is gonna be
making it to our top eight but man we
are back with more action in Group B and
we have quite the variety we have five
different countries represented and it's
gonna be a doozy I can't even think who
I mean if I was a betting man and I am
yeah I don't know to place a bet here
but I mean a lot of favorites going into
this one and I think it's gonna be hard
to say who's gonna take it I mean any
predictions on your end I mean yeah I
mean for any matchups you want to see if
you look at this you know Anakin was the
one that has been actually performing
very consistently over the over the over
this year right getting high placements
all over the shop but then you never
know man you've got five players from
five different countries so much
character variety so really it can go to
any one man and we've already seen it
look at this pool that we just saw me
and also I'm making it through no one a
lot of people picked are slanted make it
through a man but he didn't and you know
that just goes to show that on the day
it just good you know it's all about how
you're playing on the day I mean in
don't let those scores kind of dissuade
you from the standings I mean every one
of those players played out of their
minds and played their best and I saw so
many impressive reads and so many
impressive plays from all these players
I really think that could have changed
on any given day yeah definitely there
were so many final matches and you know
a lot of these were two one matches two
ones you want too much moments
everywhere exactly exactly so could have
gone either way but you know son it was
really good from him because you know
I've known recently that he said to me
that he has changed up his playstyle
half of the finals he's gone back to his
high school days someone everyone you
used to be so aggressive used to be so
so dangerous when you were when you were
younger go back to that style that's
what he's gone back to and that's why
we're seeing him do you a lot better
behave you go pool be here and the first
match is gonna be a crazy one we have
ever than my stroke vs anikan
yeah Peru versus the US of A hmm and
this one should be fun I mean I'm
looking at the matches over here and the
players that we have in in Group B and
this is gonna be their you know quite
the right like we mentioned but it's
also gonna be the first pool where we're
gonna see that character that everyone
has been training against Akuma Akuma
man Akuma has been a really big problem
everyone but like you said ever been
training against
so we saw yesterday the LCQ there were
so many people that were ready for that
macho man you know him it wasn't easy
for them to win even at the end below
didn't even go for a kuma yeah and he
was like you know what when I I'm gonna
go stick with Brian so super kuma has
his work cut out for him in this in the
school I think all right of course
Anakin getting ready but let's see what
Anakin had to say about the tournament
so far one thing about all the
competitors in the tournament there
really to be honest isn't anyone that
stands out as someone who like I want to
be really it's more about just being
prepared for everybody I feel that if I
give too much attention to one
competitor that would kind of result in
me overlooking some of the other guys
and all my teen or you know soon-to-be
20 of the guys participating in the
world finals have definitely earned
their spot and definitely earned the
right to be taking 1% seriously I'm just
kind of thinking about what kind of
potential opponents that have my face
with the group selection and everything
I think it's just a better plan to be
prepared for everybody overall a lot of
these players I've encountered in
tournaments in years past at least once
there are only like a couple of guys I
think that I haven't really faced in
tournaments for Tekken 7 so with that
said it'd be cool to get to play always
honey and maybe a song or a bell for the
first time in Tekken 7 but other than
that I think I'm really ready I've done
my homework so anybody that stands in my
way I'll take them out wow what an
answer here from Anakin you know tough
though you got to prepare for 19 other
players right it's true but his approach
is so good man that you prepare for
everyone level up your fundamentals just
be prepared generally you know it's a
very holistic approach to Tekken and
that's why he's been doing so well this
year but man able to marshal this off my
head for little bit man it's kind of
crept on omi teruko got into that top 20
- guy has been playing at a high level
for a very long time he was the only one
internationally to ever beat JDC on the
tekken tag tournament that was huge
that's when he first broke onto the
scene and Harry is right now in Bangkok
Tyler for the technology was going with
Aliza not the Eddie yeah interesting I
mean you know he has the had quite the
year I mean he was made a very
surprising top eight finish at the
Korean master event earlier this year
and that was kind of against all odds I
mean making that long ways of travel but
now he's here at the world stage
obviously qualified well into the points
and now picking
Aliza up against Anakin let's see how
this battle goes it's go first match of
Group B hey and again if you're out the
better this is our group stage we're
doing round robins trying to figure out
who is gonna tally up the highest score
and be able to qualify into our topic
there's gonna be one winner side and one
loser side in these two out of three
sets like you know the Peruvian scene
kind of broke onto the scene back intact
Tecna time to know now we see Pakistan
something come out here in Tekken 7 but
we can't forget about Peru man those
guys I'm so many strong legacy of - oh
yeah right now Heineken off to a quick
start
okay got them a little bit impatient
there on how we react to put the 4th on
one able to scoop him out of the air and
the follow through the bin
Anakin drawing first blood here in the
match up round number one ahead five now
talking it all but lights up days they
do feel that Eliza was left quite
significant II in season three you know
is having a move like 44 three which is
now doctor who puts on pool you know
it's made a little bit weak about you
know it's good to see a pose for using
her yeah he mentioned that he was only
going to be using Eliza and Eddie in the
entire Turkey has really been practicing
any other characters well that's what it
is man it's not you know in second we
don't talk about tears too much yeah
because we know the last year it was a
planner who won the world tour yeah
that's true so you know it doesn't
really matter by the terrorists it's
always you're comfortable with the
character but have you got everything
monster fighting back here in the second
round and it very very sound defensively
here not really falling for any of the
usual Eliza shenanigans
obviously does the character match up
but let's see if a Bella has a chance to
open him up you know he's had trouble
finding the range right now yeah just
like he said that man he wasn't ready to
punish tacked down for two on with rage
available now ten seconds on the top and
that's really what Anakin brings to the
table here he's his mastery of the
ranger in certain matchups all he wanted
to do [ __ ] it's a maybe rage art but look
at that he has the likely you better do
something
oh my god the big risk there goes with a
sweet able to get it ties it up one
round of beer is one second left as well
how'd it go nice no party once again
feel like you really need to low pirate
against jackass ball he has so many good
nose and a lot of the same yes three
safe load you have to load her and
that's the thing it's not only just
getting the damage I mean it low parry
is by itself it's not gonna get you a
lot of deaths but it's gonna get you the
momentum it's gonna get you the
offensive first that you need it to kind
of control the matchup it you do not
want Jack
two down yeah that's a scary thing
absolutely look at this this round is so
in Anakin's favor huge lightly hair how
can April answer back he has rage
resources as well with the down back one
comes in and the Kim takes the lead
all right here potentially able to take
the match here and if it needs one more
round you are now the bottom of the
stage here this stage does transform
once you get to the potential last round
no more walls yep then that's bad for
Eliza yeah bad for Eliza but it's not
gonna be a problem for Jackie me Jack
has some consistent options all the way
around the stage and Jack is the kind of
cancer that wants to be at mid-range so
he can utilize this long to jab is four
toward one elbow as well doesn't do
really well in that close range which is
what Abel trying to do right now ever
and him oh he gets hit by the mid the
follow-up he's in range now gives them
access to a little bit more damage but
again the risk of just dying oh the
second time we've seen in the sense of
water oh boy sliver of life for bulwa
players and the long reach of the robot
able to squeeze it out damn that was
sick Anna kid with a comeback in that
last round they're able to my stroke
doesn't want to start off this group
with a loss Anakin looking good man yeah
I mean this is a it's important to you
know start off strong and you don't want
to have all that pressure in the group
stages of whether or not you're gonna
make it and you want to have as much of
a lead in as much of a buffer as
possible going into every single one of
these matchups and it's so it's a
strange one as well because technically
World Tour Finals is a round-robin food
correct so you know that's not what we
do in the monster events oh yeah it's
completely different this is a true test
of mastery and skill versus characters
versus players and your performance is
gonna lead you into either the winter
side or looser side of the topic and
we've talked about so many times how
important it is to be in the winter side
because you do not want to take the long
way out it's gonna be such a mental and
physical strain on your game play and
you have to keep an eye on the matches
as well even if someone loses one you
know losing 2-1 is not as bad as you do
or a restore in the last match man
arsalan that last group arsalan didn't
make it through because he actually lost
a shadow - oh that affected him really a
lot and that's the thing with this
group's aging especially with what's
gonna be happening for the top and all
the players that are gonna be qualifying
all eyes are on them you have to imagine
there is one station that we're gonna be
doing we're showing every single match
yeah so these guys are studying they're
watching their
learning the tendencies of all the other
players here in this tournament
look at that nope I once again able the
monster was still I think it'd be
something of all these rounds with a
live feed and enable the master has to
fight back that's a pretty hard to do
not many characters can go coast to
coast here in violent systems oh boy oh
here we go
is he gonna use the rage oh no that's
not what he wanted but he was able to
put out the kicks uppercut yes taking
that round here but had to use those
resources but good stuff there for a
bell anyways you have really showing how
strong of a support player he is
fundamentally to be able to make these
cutbacks on Anakin this time he does
have to lightly push the to the wall
here we go he is devastating to rush
down you know about not dissuaded from
going to the air he got sniped out of
there a few times there with that board
four to one but still very confident in
this aerial space and aerial control and
look at that two round straight already
looking to tie it up and he's almost got
full bars of meters blob of the down
force who comes in gets the front combo
doesn't commit to the down for one one
tailspin Anakin and it's opportunity
that's the thing sometimes with that
Jack down for one one sometimes it'll
miss sometimes it'll bit sometimes don't
be deep enough where you can get both of
the hits yeah but you got to make sure
that you are able to come in and have
the right spacing for it oh you can add
a better punish there maybe yeah keeping
them out with weaves oh yes oh yeah
look if I keep out every go up Cup take
it to the corner nice gets the shoulder
lean keeps him at the wall here one more
he could do it guess I don't know in
again dangerous position full meter and
rage right now but nice able to jab him
in the face standing - and that's one of
the jacks best foods by not standing -
so good offensively and defensively yeah
I mean the thing is he has insurance
with the 2-1 as well right yes able to
control the space great advantage on hit
as well oh nice and he's able to convert
to the combo here he's gonna get some
decent damage with the shoulder barge
interesting combo missed I'm so curious
well that's abel off the hook oh yes
that kick that was great but he's out of
resources for being able to use it gonna
have to build up to more of that meter
he's almost come on dog walk I been
looking really good here it would be
behoove them to be able to close it out
here take some of that momentum boy from
Anakin but against the wall it's gonna
be tough Anakin is a master of
controlling this kind of space oh my
gosh he's eating it all
oh yes and the kid with the world
pressure jack can actually do that
cheers well Jack's wool game is no joke
yeah complete 50/50 Z have you got a BMI
so using the EXR kick meter has been
spent correct especially if he has you
know that from crouch down back one that
that crouching low at the wall it is so
many plus ram do you have to be very
careful at how you react after you get
hit yeah it's just a mix-up at that
point when you get hit by that wolf oh
yeah nice sidestep goes for the back for
heavy go yeah that's actually something
that's changed with Jack and that has
been adjusted over the seasons it's the
ability to be able to sidestep that move
gets the follow up and look at that bell
on the scoreboard right now and we are
tied at 1-1 and we're going to a final
decisive match up to see who will be in
the lead here for Group B I think we saw
a chicken it will keep charged at the
end of all of it yeah this guy's known
for the key charge whether it's in
matches after rounds he is ready to go
he just wants to hit all four buttons
yeah make some music but have you got
Anakin is actually now because he won
the first match gets the opportunity to
pick the stage and he's gone to an
infinite stage every charge which is a
really really good decision from it it's
the cake last man we see this often I
mean sometimes more often than not we
would see you know a counter pick with
the stage open stage for a lot of
players that feel like they have you
know superior spacing here yes look of
course like we mentioned you know jack
Aliza having really really strong wall
pressure and war game but jackman wants
to stay at that mid-range let's see can
Anakin bring it back an attic in the one
of the best back that's is around able
to create space in and out on the
lateral field so let's see what happens
here he misses the follow up doesn't get
the last hit
I wonder if that's because of Jack suede
plugging chase yeah man he got those big
hips yeah big big shoes and pick pius
yeah oh the follow up here what's it
gonna do it and and it just very very
patient here off you know chop away at
the legs yeah
get him back that life is stealing it
back oh he handed they're exactly what
you mentioned mark mind that sometimes
that that food one one is so
inconsistent in those situations in
approach it's great because sometimes
you'll be able to get that flow to get
the combo but this time not able to
always at a rate you don't money for
just poking away look at this Anakin
perfect example of how Jack needs to be
played just poking away oh honey able to
get the following mark stopping a lot of
combos it's tough and I mean sometimes
you get on the stage you're not able to
hit your stuff you got to make it work
in other places okay this is big
the follow-up here what's the mix-up go
to the world yeah oh yes guaranteed
three spots see that's the thing and the
game plan is much cheaper man oh my gosh
is he gonna go into the range art - you
should be able to close it out this time
he does so I was really cool another
really good option as well against
Jackie seems to jump over the line
get that hit and a guaranteed launch but
it is dangerous because I think you can
use the two jab and float about the air
fight complete mind games hey guys dark
wave punished here it's up at the board
- she possibly it to like me not gonna
be as dangerous as when Eliza has the
war but have it go look at that she is
taking to the skies every opportunity he
has to kind of mitigate the risk here
seeing a movement any movement out on
Anakin's and activating that e.x dive
kick and that obviously super dangerous
here but he only has one more
opportunity to do it unless he builds
more meter yeah well in his way though
Anakin business-as-usual poking away
with that back ones you have to be
careful how he reacts here oh we're
getting coordinate and the descent here
nice gets the confirmation gets the hint
over of wipe lafrana get oh all the
Whippet ish the dark wave able to get in
right now I bail one round away from
taking the lead here in Group E that
might throw one more round
needed he's trying to teach the world
right now there we go low parry
all right running up goes to the cross
shop let's see how he follows a ghost
for the min and and it right now
violating to go to a final round playing
a lot more aggressive this round bond
and it's working out for him Oh didn't
you get the hit you wanted yeah good
break on the throw though still very
fresh on the reactions and it can always
mean one of those players with great
reflexes almost got two pawns it means
ahead there it is he's got Rachel Road
available as well if he's time for a
comeback it's right now no break on the
throat oh man he's gonna have to be
careful because the meter is in play he
does not want to make a mistake oh my
gosh isn't a big opportunity Ted I don't
I don't know it's gonna be close it's
gonna be hard to tell I don't know if
this is gonna be enough there was a lot
of scaling afterwards he hit him in the
air as well and he has a lot of life as
well is this enough
I don't know no it's not and again
having a chance here this is a big
what's gonna happen oh but he's safe
das waves big sometime all that blow job
and about that maestro will take you
over Anakin two to one and start off his
group with a win
yeah I want to start here for a bell and
for Peru at the lead now in Group E
office who you only had our first match
but we're gonna get our next match up
but man that was a strong showing for
both of these players you know and it
can start off very strong taking the win
initially but I bail slowly but surely
able to turn around for himself you know
it's just so amazing man you know taking
for the longest time has been all about
you know the United States it's been
about Korea Japan and now we have you
know F of the maestro we have the
Pakistani he's doing bits as well here
it's so great to see and you know Tekken
just constantly growing and finding new
scenes out there and it's I think I feel
like this year is it's a lot of other
scenes because of the story of Pakistan
they feel like you know they wanted to
come out and show that nice as well it's
just it's amazing I feel like again like
we mentioned before and many people are
mentioned the story of arson - it's
really enabled and reunited I think the
International Tekken scene outside of
the normal hot spots I think everybody
started playing here right now you guys
can see where we're at on the group
stage right now a bell at the lead first
match of the day and I believe our next
matchup is going to be talyn's Kokomo
from South Korea going up against
Francis crazy a super a coup mock France
versus Korea now these guys have history
man so the first time they played him
tournament I believe it was Dragon or
versus Akuma ayah a coma
he brought them he
beat that ass he destroyed him he beat
that ass but then I also broke him but
he actually said that maybe I my
memories not too good but he said that
his the last time they played a
tournament which was quite recently he
said that I paid him and I I be badass
yeah so you know today I think that one
they wanted one for one at the moment
it's been back and forth I mean yeah I
saw the matchups it you were talking
about you know a little bit of a super
cumin you know he he was the able to win
the first master event of the year but
we really haven't seen him at the top
since then but he's obviously trained
let's see what he had to say about the
tournament well it's amazing really it's
done so much for the community
especially the dojo system I was seeing
new scenes rise up new players and I
remember back in the day when I started
competitive taking on tag to the game
was like on life support and now it's
like the biggest fighting game around
it's crazy and we have the tech world
tour to thank for an amazing shout outs
of course to everyone helping put
together the Tekken World Tour it's been
a fun year and it's been a really a year
of growth you're seeing more players
more regions more territories and of
course bigger and better matches than
we've ever seen yeah but just in general
you know as a European you know we're
gonna have a lot more sort of we're
gonna be a lot more we're so happy for
the technical tool because you know
before that we didn't really have a
platform upon which we could present
ourselves and our skill and super came
up before then no one knew who European
players were before that you know so
it's been really good just like super
Cooma said it's an amazing thing Harry
is on the world stage at the finals in
Bangkok Thailand once again going up
against Coco maintenant KO coma yeah and
you know super cool one of the players
that really put Akuma on the map at the
very beginning especially when Tekken 7
came out and he's been doing such a
great job representing a character he's
only been using that character I've
really not seen him use anyone else in
tournament yeah it's so funny as well
because his name is super kuma but it
was super came above in Tekken time when
he was a li and orbitting player yeah
anyways we're gonna go to the matchup
here France versus South Korea and he's
gone for Dragon over as well which is
the car to you regionally beat him with
is it gonna happen again
and you never know lightning can strike
twice but Whittle strike four
kula or will it strike for dragon up
here the sole representative of Europe
from France mas a super Akuma versus
kukoba
let's go Alice Ross now lay all right
nice able to get a nice whip punished to
open it up super Cooper has been
travelling all around the world money
went to Japan for the ahsoka challenge
ah yes in Pakistan you know I've been
all over the shop man sorry so
definitely been getting some levels up
there nice get the wall here able to
confirm to a combo very very Spartan I
mean you want to be able to get the
damage early on I think for players they
want to take the risk early on against
Akuma as well when he doesn't have the
meter to be able to punish you on
certain things
yes and you know one of the things when
Akuma does have meters especially in
this particular matchup it kind of seals
away something dragon ups best to all
especially the low swipe that comes
death if he gets blocked down to will
getting punished by down to yeah it's
only problem and that makes the change
especially the research ace of whom is
so critical is you cannot waste your
meter you will lose opportunities to
close out the match exactly yeah there
wasn't meets enough head before the
party Oh trotted off the power crash but
the down to spot comes in how a crush of
course loses to the lows oh here he gets
the flown out of the demon flip gets a
mental wall here what's he gonna do I
love that wolf guy man
yeah get out one of the carriers that
really benefitted from a lot of the
changes with new attacks and new moves
yes able to get extra wall carry oh yes
and egoistic and it goes to the easy
combos well I agree with there have you
go super Cooper right is all right might
as well this is the popular out for a
cooler they like that oh wait that
search ammo was he good yeah I feel like
a lot of more crazy but you know this is
crazy super Akuma he's been playing this
character for a long time now the og
he's been playing before he was even
available all nights good punish there
all right and that's where it counts yet
goes for the easier combo I'm getting oh
my gosh he just choked oh man he's
already now 2 :
nice one one count two hits yes super to
finish it off yeah I like it there and
then I think with that one one - it
doesn't jail so you got to have that
presence of mind be able to duck the
second 8 at least not let him get away
with an option there yeah quartz counter
hit confirm able to do it nice punish
there from super Akuma hmm I think that
meets enough is notes because at this
point before you really have to boss
yeah it's those will but I feel like you
know a lot of these adjustments a lot of
these changes they often make players
more focus and better with their
characters overall yes and look at this
down 3 once again of clean it this
should be dead if I don't come at a
classic no it's not gonna finish talking
to me about one add it to a bad trip EDC
combos right without a to a bad you
gotta kill without was gonna need Mac
man that was by quick yeah you know I
felt like Kokomo went out to the lead
early on but out of nowhere super kuma
slowly but surely started doing the
system with the cooler made it work and
it actually looked so comfortable for
super come as well which is the funny
thing like it wasn't it was a high
didn't seem hard at all here I go into
range which is usually the hard thing
when someone knows the matchup is
getting into the range for down between
here but it's been pretty easy but Akuma
he's not just backdashing yeah hashtag
just back - I don't know that works
anymore I don't know if that's a thing
but we'll see we're gonna go into the
stage select it looks like Kokomo is
gonna be sticking to dragon off hmm
and we're going to The Devil's pit
warming stage interesting that he hasn't
chosen to go for a infinite stage here
when a dragon uh does get some really
big open open combos yeah and you kind
of want to you know prevent yourself
from getting hit at the wall with Akuma
for the really ridiculous comebacks
right yeah really ridiculous come back
because that some of that stuff is only
possible with the wall
exactly and you already know super
Kuma's gonna have dice probably got the
best execution of all things with the
kuma you know these combos no one is
exempt from them dropping everybody
every one of these are players have
dropped combos oh yeah
except for me because I don't do that
anyways nice goes with the standing to
not able to the we put a capper hit
confirm into the easy copy able to build
some meter get some damage
they'd get that one won quite a bit
tries to offer again nice duck into
while standing - there we go
he dropped it down up there you've got
something up before this would like yeah
yeah yeah no you see that ye word don't
say execution man that's gonna get
people bubble guts and all nervous and
everything all right and that's not
other thing - you know he has so many
tools here especially like his focus
attack isn't ability to cancel out of
the photo section really could change
how player won't approach you that you
have to go for moves out a more compact
that recover quicker to not get caught
into this cuz that can lead to so much
damage regardless of meter allows it
side kick pressure heavy go against the
demon flips got rage available ten
seconds left on the clock
oh wait oh god the money good lord the
counter it the impatience there from
Coakley you went from running to in a
counter in from super Akuma able to
close it out and he's close to half of a
meter
yeah man a 1/1 is he working so welfare
super came up playing so well a little
demon flip pressure makes the wood back
Walters to win uh-huh the followers you
got the back - super Akuma taking his
own devices he's doing well and now he
has a great opportunity and again with
meter and play it kind of changes the
mentality you do you play the same
offensive style with drag it up are you
gonna go for down - oh my gosh nevermind
you might not be able to live it might
be a final round here why don't you and
you can down three heavy go super kuba
one round away from taking the set - -
Oh which will be such a good start for
him yeah he's looking really strong and
you know we really haven't seen a play
at the highest level determining quite
some time now I think the last time a
lot of people saw super Cooper plays
when he was playing those long sets in
Pakistan and he was getting destroyed he
was yeah but all that experience leads
up to this point here that's what you
said you said I didn't go to Pakistan
for any other reason but to get
destroyed you know that's what that's
the way you learn that's the way you get
better yeah especially if you can
understand why you lost
absolute
and right now this understanding is
going a long way cuz he is a one-round
away here from tying himself or the lead
here groupie oh oh man
the follow up here what's he gonna do oh
you have to have confidence in doing
that oh that was the slowest handshake
ever go come on that was a very very
convincing set there from super Akuma
man 2 times finalist has qualified every
single second world tour but hasn't got
out the group stages of both of them so
this this is a good start man yeah great
start I mean again this is one of those
groups just like every single one of the
groups that we have it's gonna be fierce
we don't know we it's very hard to
predict who's gonna be able to get out
yeah I mean I think a lot of people that
went into this pool probably saw Oh
super Akuma's here let me play give a
chant think that was the pool that
filled up first right it was it was and
it was interesting you see yeah so I
mean you know I don't know maybe it was
a mistake man see blue came all that
practice is paying off man
yeah have a look at the at the group so
yes everything maestro and superhuman
are taking the wins over come on Anakin
respectively and our next match is going
to be double you why use double from
Japan going up against rocks dragons
about the maestro from Peru yeah a bell
of course we saw him with the win
earlier on against Anakin he was able to
close it out now going up against one of
Japan's best with this martial law
specialist hmm I have a question do you
think that any loss hair could be
considered an upset with these with the
guys that are like you know these are
the top 20 in the world it's it's hard
because you know looking in this group
we talked about you know how much of the
variety but so aside from maybe super
Akuma and kokum are seeing those guys
play and maybe Anakin and Kokomo seeing
them play recently yeah we haven't seen
these other guys match up especially
about a bell has not at least in this
later half they're been traveling we do
have some words from a beldo let's see
what he had to say about the event so
far
SN y para el torneo Master Chief when
Korea
former officials porque SF is Dell Dell
taking jakkayya knows my simple rule
siempre muchos amigo meals on querido we
had a courier para poder compartir con
players at antonio el he could work if
we know the loss dead of player que que
mas a position or my ancestor mmm which
I had to confirm me but a poor skater
once and oh you got a home toward your
normal f it up at all pero como D say no
nobody the de lucha after looting o
Segundo hasta luego Volpe don't stop
fighting until the last hit the last
second I love that man never over till
it's over been such a great lesson that
you have to kind of reiterate with
fighting games in with competition you
can't give up until the very end and I
want to stress do you know that Peru and
Pakistan that kind of similarities
between the two scenes where it's very
hard to than the travel and he said that
you know when I went to Korea was a
dream for a lot of us to actually go
then he managed to get top and like you
mentioned mark so I mean showers to him
and I'm not full on all the Peruvian
scene man I know they're gonna be
watching at home hoping for that boy to
do well and he's already gonna win on
the boat can you get another one here
he's going up against you I use double
from Japan I'll give you the best low
player in the world
yeah let's see what the matchup is gonna
be I'm not sure if you were able to see
which characters they pick but we know
double is gonna be picking law right who
is a belt gonna be bringing out is gonna
be any Gordo is it gonna be Eliza well I
think the Eliza peak was good versus
Jack because of crushes you can put on
bar maybe we'll see some Eddie here Ida
Bosch away
Eddie's not too good festival I don't
know who knows April the Marshalls
Eddie's good man
I'm gonna I'm gonna guess that Liza all
right well we're gonna go into the
matchup let's see how this is gonna play
out again important that you are correct
we have allies on the stage we're going
to the arena Walt stage mmm-hmm law
became a lot better of us as Eddie in
Tekken 7 he wasn't that good in Tekken
o'clock he came a lot better against a
lot of the cast yeah you know he may
have sacrificed sub damage options
especially at the wall but in the open
able to get a little bit more damage
still very solid with the toolset that
he has I got the pieces all the golden
suit
yeah I've been sucked up you got to
dress up it's finals day baby yeah all
right starting off with the low kick to
the dark wave oh look there's a big
count at Heat
look at that magic timing he got that a
lot against Anakin as well it's the
beautiful timing they call a double the
speed star so his ability to adjust it
just really execute on the field is
almost a parallel from a lot of the
players here let's see if he's able to
make this comeback would never buy yeah
let me use my meter nice tophat from
both taking the first bold suit versus
gold uppercut what's gonna win now
double as a play we smash to him at the
LCQ really on the big stage last year
when he came second to Yolanda a brutal
loss I mean he really took that
emotionally and he told himself that he
really wanted to make a difference the
following year obviously did very well
points wife able to qualify without
having to go through that grueling LCQ
experience I heard he also has
tournaments named after him as well when
he was younger like in Japan yeah yeah
yeah that was actually back in the day -
yeah follow up here able to close out a
bill we were just talking about you know
reminiscing about back in the days and
he's up to zero right now look at Korea
top a this guy's getting close to the
top play in the finals that's the thing
you know he's been practicing slugging
it out really kind of refining his
gameplay over the past few months we
haven't seen him in the master of it
yeah but he has been grinding it out and
look at it he is prepared here at the
world final just lucky just he got the
points to qualify then you were just
grinding out here in the South America
oh boy look at that though double on to
impact yeah and very solid play really
controlling that round but is it gonna
be enough because right now he does have
meter again mm-hmm Oh
slidy yes time to sell that slide
pressure now I mean sometimes you have
to take those were sometimes you have to
put your body out there and slide across
the floor
oh no break when the 1+2
yeah nes position he's gonna be right by
the wall you gotta be careful how you
approach this all white guys to go
through the low does either reboot dog
tiny both rows back yeah doctor and that
might have been it and this is
definitely gonna be a one more mix up
one more hit will do it but double come
to the ball oh man you went for the four
and one for the dss big
a nice little sidestep therefrom able to
make the slash kick with yeah and that's
danger too I mean the running slash kick
is a great move to cover ground in very
advantageous but you could easily step
it if you have enough time most of them
are very very linear if not all of them
yeah so brilliant stuff good lateral
movement there by Emmel de Maistre man
he's looking strong mark yeah he's
looking what was doing I don't know he
was preparing man he was preparing
obviously for this day he knew he was
qualified decided to take some time off
and just really refine everything and
you know it's been working out for I
think everyone that knew about the
master from tag to knew that this guy
had the potential to be here yeah but
even if he last year he was at the LCQ
didn't make it out oops you know in the
LCQ but look at how he's turned it
around he's here now he's already got to
win over Anakin looking very strong
versus double as well someone who has
been actually winning a technical tour
events so can table the marshal closes
out here round one there we go second
game another wool stage here both
characters do get a lot of wool damage
and wool pressure so double choosing to
go from a small stage here we go again
just finding his facing here early on
they're kind of slowing it down but
right now double opting to go for more
risks there oh he goes for the down for
two that's really the first time we've
seen him kind of employ that tactic here
gets the wall dragon cannon
big boy damage Oh in the slide he has a
nice lead here nice he's dashing to
block back one two
I like it everything maestro let's see
how he answers back goes for the jump
back at the start of the round slipping
familiar we've really seen over and over
was that kind of guaranteed was that
counter yet I don't know yeah trying to
find that spacing here again right now
Koval seems to be in full control right
now got the read on it he's done this so
many times enjoyment double just time to
get around yeah well he has a hill to
climb right now he's still down 1 0 that
would be the right time but full meter
for our Bell let's see if that bells
able to employ anything and the rage as
well oh my gosh and that is the
specialty I think from double his
ability to the sidestep and also utilize
a while rising one two yeah cover so
much ground every beautiful hit come
there as well so two rounds up in quick
succession hair double DP he gets a
punish but I mean that sometimes you
just want to go for the large get the
wall distance this is definitely gonna
push to the wallet see what kind of
combo and what kind of mix I'm Karina
have right here jacket look at that last
hit he keeps up there yeah not being
able to use it means I can use it no he
touch the string but no launch and
that's unfortunate I'm because he had
the right read he was able to get the
duck the defensive reaction but not able
to get a launch and go the other way
yeah Oh guarantee punish medical the
great punish as well yeah knowing that
the 3+4 not safe here we go that Jimmy
range art is that gonna kill though I
think it will I think it will - yeah and
look at that double three straight round
someone else's farm
oh my gosh that was a big gamble there
yeah but great patience there from
double able to kind of snip that one out
yeah
realizing haven't be awareness that he
had the the meter available to do DX DP
double staying calm and very experienced
in tournament not gets the opportunity
to change the stage going to the violet
systems have the final match there's
nice throw was a very good combat there
from double
how is ever gonna turn it around if he
wins this match he'll that b2o
up would you put me in a very very good
position yeah I mean it could go either
way I mean I really thought I bel was
coming out strong able to close it out
early on he was very aggressive and able
to really control the pacing of the
match but out of nowhere double three
sheet rounds man yeah stolen the
momentum back heavy going for the side
and that's one thing that he wasn't
doing that fast man just slide yeah one
of the quickest guns with the slide able
to shoot from all corners nice punish
that is so good locked and loaded ready
for this time catching him with the mid
nice I mean it's a homing attack it does
its job yeah gosh again double up some
adaptations being made head by a belt
but double my out of it yes anybody's
match here gets counter hit on the
banana peel snipe them out of there but
didn't get the combo that he wanted all
power to the people ready for that with
the big launch and look at that he's
gonna close it out now double officially
in the lead here on the set - this is
very very good stuff and doubled about
the master was in control that last
round but that was stole it back I said
this guy's still commencin is a thief
nice this time trying to restrict the
movement here you know I thought has it
really been sidestepping too much use it
any player right sometimes they don't
slack step but I mean using these
tracking moves to kind of lock them down
and look at he's just chasing him down
down a nice punish has an opportunity
goes for the mid option again yeah dog
wave trying to keep him out couple finds
his way a nice no punishment down by
three and it's all watching it below
parry oh he missed the follow-up it
doesn't matter if first you don't
succeed try try again
look at that one round away is double
gonna be able to give a bell his first
loss in the group stage it's looking
good for him ferment some ornateness
head it goes for the junkyard yes s nice
sidestep doesn't get a huge punish on it
though she wasn't meter no block on the
slide grown up into down for two as well
you can hear the Japanese getting loud
in the crowd all the follow up here
landed right on it he was looking to
close it out this this is very dangerous
oh go straight for the rage awesome
alright he's maximizing the combo
potential here from that read he does
have a meter left let's see what he does
with it this is the position no mouth
stays alive but it there's a dive kick
your back at neutral what's gonna happen
yes know me to left oh he's good on his
comeback here
oh I like it able to low jab right
underneath the string and I'm Bell
taking his first loss double now hmm
undefeated so far after his first match
oh boy
you why use double after losing the
first match quite convincingly bringing
in fact that shows experience you might
be a young luck but this guy's
definitely got a lot of to experience oh
yeah wow so able to maestro now one and
one in this group great stuff so far so
next matchup I believe both of our
players getting ready we have
radiance Red Bull Anakin from the United
States going up against crazy super
Akuma from France that should be the
next matchup I'm excited to see that one
you know these guys recently were on the
same team when we had an international
exhibition and the one sports event in
Japan yeah and obviously those guys did
alright but now they're gonna have to
clash these guys shared a lot as far as
you know training and mentality going
into the event but now they're gonna
have to clash it I think
might be able to help out kind of carry
to carry that one that definitely did a
lot of work for the team he had him on
his back man but yeah Anakin obviously
this is gonna be a Jack this is a
creamer matchup and we need to talk
about this because Jack has his has been
seen historically as the character that
is kind of like kind of pick against a
few mafia because of his really strong
anti-air options right yeah but on the
other hand super kuma has done well
first Jack plays you know he's done
really well versed in the Roma in the
past in long sets and in tournament and
he has options to like punish from some
of the uppercut which is -14 you can get
phone no internet I mean I don't know I
think this is all gonna come down to
who's feeling it most on the Dame we've
already seen super Kumar you know we are
solid solid class game does it coma
yeah I think it's totally gonna come
down to the field and the right reads
but you know I have a really strong
feeling here and you know usually I
don't make these kinds of pretty nice
but I have a strong feeling that Anakin
it's gonna be very comfortable in this
player matchup
okay just because of the history these
guys have oh yeah I think they might
have even played as wrong to him and it
would have gone it would have gone to
Anakin don't quote me on that though but
we're definitely gonna see it now though
have you got handshakes all around Akuma
versus Jack USA versus EU there's like
two French guys in this crowd look out
loud they are
the French Jocelin la la oh we're taking
it to the warm of the cereal doing with
the cereal bellissimo it's an ollie Yu
ting of course the sole representative
from EU hair there are a couple of
Americans in this tournament
Jimmy they will be coming up later how
crazy is it then Akuma's in the game I
know when it's pretty crazy it's crazy
anyways back into the matchup here goes
to the downfall and able to kind of
scoop it out here comes Anakin Anakin is
playing with confidence right now he's
like what are you gonna do you have no
meter once you get oh my gosh he gets
the one wad looks like it was counted
but didn't confess Yannick and also one
of those players that experiments and
uses a lot of the cast especially when
you play casually in training at home so
he obviously knows what it takes to be
able to use Akuma in a matchup knows the
holes those options oh my gosh wit milk
it's really anakin using a lot that down
for salt which is a safe and low use
that meter there now at the mercy of
Anakin because Anakin's about to rush it
I mean he has no meter oh my gosh we're
punish there the Wumpus to have you go
full combo taking a closer to the wall
tackles it reverses it there we go
yeah who try the koomer that he didn't
go through the power crush on issues the
sanding to punish women looking good
hair and he finish it how do you added
they're very close very very super
Kimble on the board alright one round a
piece we're all tied up
nice counter hit able to get early on
yeah the conservation you should be able
to push some with the wall if he doesn't
drop it there always combo not the best
combo definite super Kumar look at the
walls flap and it getting good position
right now what's he gonna do with the
gun max range that William axis of range
now he keep cement the wall here in a
low period the right read on the little
toe get up Rach available no part meters
house can be bad to super command it can
take in the round that was a very very
strong offensive spurt there from Anakin
just like we talked about might have not
standing to he has so many good anti-air
options yeah try and stay with his feet
on the ground here guaranteed hit this
is where it scary - this is back is to
the wall there's the debug the call up
here oh I have to pull it out sometimes
you have to take these big risk here you
know that's a very risky low booth
he's been landing it but I don't think
Anakin care about each unit I get him
yeah I see massive life he and I can
take in the first match and you could
feel it too you know Anakin playing with
the air compass he gets up he just
throws the move out cuz he knows that
it's either gonna get blocked or he's
either gonna hit it yeah it's been
working out right now Akuma super Akuma
is gonna have to make some adjustments
here he goes straight into the rematch
yeah yeah I don't see him needing to
really change the stage or anything it's
not looking about that it just needs to
make the adaptations you know try not to
stay and not try not to jump too much
because anakims you so the two tab is
really really good you can also get
antsy ed with the downfall to uppercut
as well so yeah great list okay
wait it's crazy to like you hit it early
enough you'll still be able to get a
conversion hits of distance and combos
and look at that closing it out man
Nikita's running away with this right as
crazy as long you still addict it with a
sidestep you know with such a big body
contour I think it is still the low car
yet stalling around yeah here we go
again
much like we saw in the last round and
again playing out his bite here trying
to keep them there nice oh where are you
going I could see the future heat you
get over here
this man can see the future is it gonna
be seven golden he's working on it oh he
went for it tried to fish out a counter
hit doesn't matter you know that's gonna
get launched in yeah look at that
Anakin right now trying to run away with
you on set point now having got Anakin
looking super super solid I would say
man in the player matchup I feel like
Anakin is super confident it is showing
right now yeah what do you have that
read I use gonna teleport I think that's
that's player knowledge right there now
what's gonna do it again has meter so
Akuma is super dangerous there's the
Knights will punish Oh No instead of
getting a full combo he actually got
punished for it as well happens you
don't finish your combos man gotta
finish your plating right now he's in
the worst position possible don't
teleport again don't do it today oh my
god good break though Anakin is really
feeling slow because he only does that
when he throws but man look at that that
was probably the most one-sided math you
see the entire day I think so I
definitely think so man that was crazy
you know the the awareness and you know
just everything from Anakin being ready
for the ante as every time poking away
knowing what Akuma was gonna do that was
very very convincing yeah very very nice
and Anakin on the scoreboard now able to
get a point here in the group stage but
Manchu OH as well which is very
important yeah especially operation for
calculating of the games you know it's
gonna count especially if there's a
tiebreaker situation but man more
matches of course I'm super excited
about how cool B is playing out and I'm
scared I'm actually scared because we
might have another you know nail-biter
we've got four guys on one one right now
so I think it might very well come down
to that situation mark right now we have
a Japan vs. career match we have talents
Tacoma who had a very bad start to this
group already versus double from
Pam yeah he was the first victim to the
shake my hand he was the first victim in
and double you know he had a really
strong showing he started I guess he
struggled early on maybe again Cybele he
made some adjustments but was really
able to clean it up and dominate at
least in the last two matches but we do
have some words from Pokemon let's see
what he had to say
[Music]
Misaki isotonic assault losing Ichiro
Suzuki optimally using my kimochi or
turning chicken
[Applause]
[Music]
happy he said we ready in time what do
you wear now baby bench is it that's
probably one of my favorite memories to
play the cosplay I was the same man to
cover what personality I was thinking
though use like oh my favorite memories
when I went toward was also everything
how many one lucky
this guy's comes second so many times I
mean that's why he has so many points
any qualified so early on he was in a
good comfort zone but you know he did
win one or two events right
he won't polish yeah yeah yeah
definitely always up there top three so
consistent shoutouts to the crowd right
now you can see him in the back waving
their arms getting high is Korea vs.
Japan hey man
a classic bakoma versus double the
Japanese people have been very very loud
in the crowd there man both days for the
LCQ and today
the confident big numbers you know so
much has changed in I guess the
hierarchy of you know player talent over
the past few years you know Korea
everyone used to say Korea was the
dominant scene right and yet so much
this game has really been globalized as
far as you know the talent the players
in the tournament victories and it's
insane to see how much the World Tour
has really been a World Tour this year
yeah and it was it wasn't it wasn't like
the game got worse the game is bought
better and we still have this player
diversity
no knock on the Koreans I mean they're
still amazing right yeah but it's just
nice to see so many other countries
stepping up their games being able to
compete against everyone else in the
world it's truly a world tour Bob yeah
and uh man these guys really brought the
outfits to the World Tour party
we got the gold suit versus the cowboy
outfit cowboy pull honey
nice okay Kokomo's first time using paul
here in the group stages let's see what
he does with it against the wall as well
it doesn't work out you know it brings
out the Korean Street goes about to
jacket off yeah he's even used you know
double J paws to me he's been using a
lot of these characters he has a lot of
characters is arsenal
yeah I what you gonna do ghost in sight
devil man kind of changing up the rhythm
a little bit seed evolution nice say we
go somewhere the first round yeah able
to close it I'm clean movement as well
but if he wins this match this will
throw everything into chaos this is a
crazy match to at least lure wise I mean
this is like team best friends man
they're going at it okay nice once
anyone doesn't get a confirmation he
tries to go for this down forward to
chopping away have you got oh wow right
underneath the boats got to try to find
the opening there it is not funny Stefan
could come across 93 boys gets the big
launch the lift to the follow up Hugh
should get the dragon cannon as well
what's the mix-up what you gonna do now
Paul just sneaking his way out of the
corner mm-hmm you know how my fish for
those plus frames I advantage have you
gonna put stubble enrages dangerous now
both kinds of Rachel Oh his patented
while standing one two double able to
take that round here what you gotta
watch out mmm kokumo got those boots on
boots and the Spurs okay nice rushing in
really closing the distance here
forcing double to react with all these
quick folks but again again he's so good
with that just like you said - sidestep
ducking to confirm it wast anyone oh
that look at this could be dad yeah and
the thing is like you the way you want
to be able to stop that it's get in his
face and use moves that are able to
track the downpour to the art of the
intercepting fist gee kundo able to make
it work yeah
punished uh what you do don't look at it
oh yeah
you barely utilize that move there that
DSS for ya big counter hit he goes with
the easy Demoman combo the ball what's
gonna do good Oh doesn't confer
yeah he's ki he got to be careful he
hasn't been the red one I could do it I
say we go find our first game sometimes
it's all about the jab whoever controls
the left controls the world
sometimes the jab is all you need keep
them honest here we go all next block
this is really good position wise with
that boy comes got to get out of there
that's nice down 4-2 does just that take
this to the wall as well
crazy will splat big Gryphon Apple - no
/ - come on this is going right down to
the wire here for the first game he's
able to close it out here it looks like
it's gonna be enough here it will be in
our code coma loses the first match with
a huge commitment dead double was so
ready
ducked the string while signing - and
took the match is he gonna take a
breather here are we gonna see maybe a
possible character switch stage select
or he's gonna go right into the Rio
Rancho what's it gonna be this that's
the hard choice right because it was
such a close match it was final round
and he came right down to the wire so it
does he switch character or you know
it's a hug I think he's got the stage
that test I'll take you report yeah he's
gonna stick to fall lots of love to of
course everybody here in the arena and
everybody that's tuning at home watching
on twitch TV whether you're watching
here on the official channel or one of
the many restreams from our community
thank you for watching Tekken so let's
spread the word make sure you guys let
everyone know twitch.tv slash Tekken and
we're gonna be going at it for many more
hours from here on out there are so many
sick matches yet to come a lot of
countries diversity which i think is the
amazing thing right yeah it's how much
diversity there is injustice top 20
makes it very interesting I mean a
really boring if it was just 20 Koreans
or Tony Japanese you know I mean like
it's really good that we have this
diversity and it speaks to how how how
global Tekken is yeah it's it's it's
quite the treat I mean this is probably
my favorite I mean it's not even over
yet it's probably my favorite World
Finals that we've had thus far yeah and
I mean we're not even at the nitty
gritty and we're not even at the top
basis pools man this is pools man all
right here we go
he is picking Paul again we are now in
outpost our jungle outpost - turning up
the tunes here they drop my base let's
see what happens all right
pumping pedal nice block there good
reaction goes through the legendary kick
yeah oh try up the delay hop kick as
well oh yeah you try to get that cheeky
Bob kick oh it means the you gotta
remember that means sometimes it's kind
of scary to react to that new quarter
should go back to reaching cuz he does
have a bit option afterwards now yeah
you got to react sometimes you want to
move too soon - even in his face look at
this yeah that's one way to cover ground
right
and if generally as well - opening me
yesterday he goes that you know the
Koreans and someone who plays a quite
respectful they'll let you kind of test
that defense which is really difficult
as well when you plane can someone ask
that's crazy that double yeah and let's
think these guys are playing such a
high-octane high speed exchange up close
man it's really hard to tell I me double
like we were talking about gets so much
mileage off using the one to sidestep
into in civilizing one to right and
that's that's a quick move right so the
he has to be able to react and kind of
create space so quickly nice double
dragon the follow up you should be able
to get the wall break here yes I'm gonna
go mm bolt downstairs poison arrow good
yeah oh he's wearing that used car
salesman suit he definitely has a poison
arrow in his pocket sigh step again pump
the pedal what's he gonna do with it oh
nice dunk and that's all he wasn't
expecting it though [ __ ] you know I mean
he could have done the range or he could
have done so many things in this bag and
he finishes it with the rage ah he
didn't even have to and we're going to
oh no it's uh yeah even up to even up
the round
flag on the play unnecessary roughness
whoop that was way too much that's crazy
I mean that's the thing is he got in
that situation before right it was the
block rage drive and he got hit by the
Demoman last time this time he even mix
it up you up for a snake - into the
quarter for three and he was able to low
very still
that is a cornice definitely doping for
me man Oh a nice count here from Tacoma
and he's gonna get the conversion with
the elbow and he drops the combo that's
not a good position broken plane told
him ourselves man man Kakuma selling it
right now this is not looking good for
him
oh yeah he's trying to put him over
let's see what happens here goes with
the tracking attacks again tough going
both ways and now in rage gotta watch
out for the wall standing more - oh boy
I have a bad feeling about this
that could look at the space control
right now please flash ducky you can see
him he wants it yeah
[Applause]
initiating the slo-mo sequence
my heart is not moving right now so koo
kumba tried to punish the load but
double finish the string which no one
ever does but yes my double is crazy man
that's the thing is like he had to
punish the right punish and it was the
wrong move buddy okay follow up here he
has a near the wall and looking really
good for double right now but also
looking good for Kokomo yes it breaks
the wall have you go good stuff there
only one set point range good for Kokomo
oh dude he just threw it out hmmm okay
well double huh you know he's known as
that player who likes to take risks he
did it last round did it here again one
final round second game are we gonna see
a tie at set or will it be two over
double that's so important when it comes
down to the standings peeling those
bananas get the follow up here flash
elbow to the follow up again using that
punishment getting so much mileage out
of it and get the float you might be
able to push towards the wall that could
be in that's all I got oh my god not
like this he might be throwing it away
come on like this plus frames do that do
that low kick the flip kick again crazy
I don't know if this comeback is gonna
be 100 not gonna happen could call my
putting into that right away with the
QCF three records your final match man
that was nerve wrecking
to say the least this man that was crazy
yeah doubles down easy he's nuts
by together such a high speed sometimes
you gotta slow it down
yeah but it speaks to Co comas defense
as well that I was able to actually you
know live through this you know he
managed to do bout the adversity and
take it to a head and survive survive
yeah he has momentum now he needs this
win Kokomo's already lost one and it was
200 as well in favor of super Akuma so
it's not looking good for he needs this
win very very badly
alright precipice of fate and this is
gonna be the final match between these
two again crucial points are on the line
here man the season is already over but
points are still on the line this is my
high five toss to Steve have you got a
final match precipice of fate
just push it away now getting closer to
threats Latino with that down for two
he's gonna have the wall here dragon
conn-young uh-huh
again keeping that pressure right now
he's running him over running him over
hit him with that old same song the duck
wall sided one soon
that's his favorite man has that jam on
repeat look at this aggression mock yeah
man he is he's working that magic right
now getting so much mileage of blows now
he's really put the fear into Kokomo
yeah at least from these folks taking
more liberties offensively when you come
one does get started it's really really
good for him fight you just need to get
that initial hair hair it is I need to
drop this might get a full punish yeah
now it has the metal wall here let's see
how he plays with it what's he gonna do
there we go nice job pressure Oh
oh my gosh the clutch notaries oh don't
get song oh my god big whipped up
punished I'm so scared I can't say
anything oh no respect from the frames
double even with the disadvantage just
threw it out there now he's on set point
once again that is so scary
just seeing that key charge knowing that
the next hit could be your death you
don't even want to throw anything out
yeah cuz the key charge give you a count
it yeah
oh my gosh Kokomo's best I've got
shaking your head yet seven gold this is
why I wanted to see from Cobra I'm gonna
shake your hand when I win not now
have you gone can we see some more
aggression from Coco mine's working out
for him I'd like to see him just you
know go nuts go in with the Demoman
going with the death pennies creating an
opportunity for himself this could be
elimination from it for for him hey
monkey if he loses oh that's right yeah
he's already lost two match earlier
today this is crucial for a battery dog
doesn't get the combo there does down
for three instead the whole yeah he's
been fighting to make your head he drops
the cup on the crucial point this is a
bad look when he gets to clean it there
so this could be a clock it might be in
if he gets the wall it's gonna be all
over hey
that's gonna be a double we'll take it
over to come back up ahead in hands I
think he knows how important that match
was and of course a really really big
drop as well yeah there we go
Tacoma of course such a passionate
player as well you know definitely
wanted to get the win there he was so
close but double just to plot on the day
mock sadly :
that'sthat's two losses now he's in a
very very bad position I don't know if
if that means that he's out but uh you
know it's definitely not where you want
to be all right and you guys can see the
standings right now unfortunately kokum
but now Owen - in the pool yeah making
it very very hard for him to really do
anything I mean it may be at this point
all he can do is play spoiler I mean
looking at everyone else double is
looking obviously in great position
right now I was supposed yeah but he
still has more matches to play as do
many of the other players in our group
so right now if come on wants to have a
chance he's gonna really have to hope
double wins all at the rest of his
matches yeah that he that he goes and
you know comes goes forward out and you
know just it's gonna come down to
whether he can win his next two matches
I think if you win if you lose another
match that is guaranteed he's gonna be
out so man we have to crack on though we
have to crack on it's gonna be super
Akuma versus I bail then maestro it's
gonna be an interesting match as well
because I know when a bail came to
Amsterdam for the LCQ last year a lot of
Europeans beat him you know so maybe
maybe I mean he'll be used to the eddy
and the Elijah we have allies as strong
allies in Europe but yeah I think we're
gonna get right into the action but
first we are gonna take a quick break
and we're going to be